[Música]
humo y vagones carbonizados estos restos
dan cuenta de la violencia de la
colisión entre un tren de pasajeros que
se descarriló y un tren de mercancías
todavía en las vías el choque generó un
incendio y muchos pasajeros quedaron
atrapados en el interior de los vagones
oímos un gran estruendo Fueron 10
segundos de Pesadilla estuvimos dando
vueltas en el vagón hasta que caemos de
costado y hasta que se suele alboroto
Entonces cundió el pánico había cables
por todos lados el incendio fue
inmediato Mientras nos dábamos la vuelta
nos estábamos quemando había fuego a
derecha e izquierda
bajamos y un incendio había empezado a
nuestro lado este hombre aquí vio un
agujero Así que conseguimos salir de
donde estábamos
los pasajeros heridos fueron trasladados
a hospitales de la región para recibir
tratamiento mientras que otros fueron
evacuados a salónica ya se han
confirmado decenas de muertos y varios
pasajeros permanecen en estado crítico
en el tren que viajaba de Atenas a
salónica viajaban unas 350 personas por
el momento la causa del accidente sigue
sin estar Clara